[Music]
hello i'm dominic monaghan
and i'm billy boyd we are here in los
angeles for the first time
not in los angeles but for the first
time doing
this podcast it's very exciting dom
have you been invited onto a podcast
before i have i always ignore it
you just it's not your thing i don't
like getting out of bed
but that but for this you thought well i
will get out of bed for this because
this is mine
and also it's don monahan who's one of
my favorite
people in the whole world including dogs
oh that's sweet so we decided a while
ago
to do a podcast which by the way welcome
you guys are listening to it right now
it's called
the friendship onion welcome to the
friendship onion and we should probably
talk a little bit about why the
friendship onion but also
why podcasts right yeah since
to be honest bills everyone's doing a
podcast right now it doesn't matter to
me dom so
what makes this rise above all the mess
don monahan really yeah well thanks mate
because i'll tell you what it is dom
as you know since we were together
on like that now on lord of the rings
when we met on that
pretty much since we have been talking
about doing things together and we've
done a couple of things we've done
a cartoon you know we've done you know
little bits voice-overs
but we've always been looking for the
best thing
that we can sort of enjoy our friendship
and do something entertaining and fun
right and make it natural since we do
spend
genuinely quite a lot of time together
because we've now been living in the
same city for what a decade
yeah i mean obviously we lived in
britain together but then billy moved
over to the states
we spend a huge amount of time with each
other
i've been into podcasts for a long time
and you started to get
interested what like a couple of years
ago yeah it was really you dumb you said
you should listen to podcasts and i
didn't really get it at first
but now even on the drive over here i
was listening to podcasts i really enjoy
them
what was the moment for you when i
introduced you to the idea of podcasts
and maybe exploring it where
the penny dropped and you went oh hang
on a second i get it i get what this is
about
i don't know if there was a moment but i
just thought it's
it's a genuine sort of medium isn't it
it's
you know if we were listening
to a beatles album this week and you
said to me
you know what i would love to talk about
this it's such an
interesting thing i would like to be
able to discuss this
there's no other more honest medium to
do that i think
in podcast yeah the platform is so free
obviously back in the day we had radio
but there's only a finite amount of time
for you to listen
to radio and listen to radio hosts this
now seems to be
you guys can listen to a podcast
whenever you want
however you want for however long you
want you can go back into archives
you can listen to it once and think okay
i'm going to move on something that
sounds like it there is a huge amount of
artistic freedom in there so with that
in mind
what's this one going to be about
because we can go anywhere exactly
i mean obviously we met on load of rings
so i'm pretty sure that's going to pop
up
quite a lot i mean i think it'll
probably pop up
in this episode we've already mentioned
it once
yeah just then yeah and i think at some
point we'll probably do
deeper dives into lordran's because that
is
probably the number one thing that
people ask me about when i'm out and
about is it the same for you
yeah i would think so unless somebody
asked me you know what it was like to
work on lost
oh don't even get me started on
how was russell crowe to work with or
someone coming over to me and going
fool of a tuck and i go no no that's the
scottish one
and then they go well whereabouts in
scotland are you from and i go no no
that's billy and like we have said
doesn't it
we've signed things for the other person
because the
the person asking for the autograph will
not take no for an answer yeah someone
will bring over a picture of you
and i look at it and i think well that
that's not me
but they probably don't care so i just
signed on monahan and i don't
necessarily
this is interesting because i don't
necessarily think that it's because we
look like each other
because same-ish high same
same you know elements of the way that
we look but
yeah different eye color different nose
shape different jawline
different style yeah i think it's more
along the lines of
mary and pippin are very seldom seen off
camera
yeah and people just are not quite sure
which ones which was marion
in fact on set as i'm sure you remember
there were people that worked with us
throughout the entire production which
was like almost two years
where they would call us billy don or
don billy because they didn't know the
difference
sometimes i get confused so i i often
find myself being a little envious of
the journey the individual journey that
elijah went on or shawn aston went on as
hobbits
because you can't confuse frodo and sam
do you know what i mean do you think
anyone ever confuses orlando bloom with
john reese davis
i don't think so no probably not no so
we will talk about lord of the rings
obviously yeah we're also going to talk
about our life
as actors because we're still
having our job to do and then that's
another thing to think about
what if you get a job that takes you to
italy for three months how do we do this
i've thought about this dom
i say we still do it we'll take the mic
whoever has to go somewhere takes the
microphone with them
you know we'll we'll clear this with
cast media yeah we're not just going to
stay
we're not going to we don't steal
microphones but we'll take them with us
and then we'll still do the podcast and
say i am in italy
then you can ask me about italy and say
have you had a pizza yet and i'll say
yeah at the delicious one last night
bella bella
right because at some point we were
going to talk about like a specific
food from a specific country or a
specific drink and we could do that
authentically
if this is the thing authentic i love it
john
and this is what it's about we're just
going to have anecdotes
we'll talk about movies we'll talk about
music it's just conversation
between a couple of old friends i love
it in fact just before we started
talking about this
yeah we had mentioned that at some point
in the show
maybe we'll talk about a specific moment
in
lord of the rings yeah the the movies
and i said
it will it will act in some way as a
thirst trap
and you said oh what's the thirst trap
and i said wait wait let's talk about it
on the show so do you genuinely not know
what a thirst trap is
i honestly don't know what a thirst trap
is it's like a
social media term carry on used by
youths younger than us in which someone
might
post something up that is asking for
a reaction usually in a slightly
flirtatious way
so maybe like a guy has been working
really hard in the gym
and he wants to show people on instagram
so for the first time in a long time
maybe he'll take his shirt off and say
yeah what do you think of this or
someone's showing off a new pair of
shoes
or a new car that they've bought it's
it's a little bit like clickbait but
with a leaning towards
something a bit flirty that's nice that
i've learned see what i've done there
dom
i've learnt something today in this
podcast this is kind of why we're here
first trap do you think we should move
on because as well as us talking about
stuff we want to have other people
involved oh that's right as you know
interactive it's interactive there's
going to be questions voicemail there
might even be quizzes
so if you've got like a burning question
about lord rings or about billy or about
me or about anything associated with
that
you can call in we'll give you all this
information at the start of the show
no maybe the end of the show start the
show be stupid yeah i don't know that
information yet but we already have
people that have called in
well can we listen to that or can we
read it what how does it work
we're just finding out we're looking
through the window to the engineers and
producers
of cast media who are now pressing
buttons that's the great thing about
episode one is it's very meta you're
seeing us
in real time mess it up basically
hey billy and dom uh this is pete
i gotta know how many times did you read
the books in preparation for the shoot
and which book was your favorite thanks
so much
that's a good question from pete do you
want to answer that one first
just to clarify when he says books do
you just mean general books
or does he mean the lord rings he is
specifically talking about the lord of
the rings
okay it's a great question pete
i i'd read lord rings when i was about
15 or 16 there was a very tattered
copy in my mom and dad's house and my
dad had told me for years
just wait to read that wait you're not
quite ready yet at 12 13 i was asking he
was like well it's like a thousand pages
you might want to wait you might want to
wait i'd already read the hobbit
listen to the bbc in home recordings of
the hobbit radio play
wonderful fantastic and then when i got
to
1516 maybe 16 i think
he had said now you're ready but the
cover had slightly come off and the back
pages had slightly
come off so i was always nervous that
you're gonna get to the end of the book
yeah
and maybe the last three or four pages
weren't there you know yeah
yeah what about you when did you well
here's the thing
you saying that the the cover is coming
off i could have helped you with that
dom
because as you know before i was an
actor i was a book binder
i made books and one of the books that i
made
was lord of the rings and i used to read
every book that i used to make in the
factory
except lord of the rings too big it just
felt like too much of a commitment
and never get around to reading it when
i left work
i i i gave up on printing and i
i uh went to drama school but
i had three months off and i went to
florida for some reason
just you me and girlfriend at the time
and we hung around the floor of the keys
and i took lord of the rings with me and
this was an absolute true story
first day there went down to the pool
with ladder rings
and i dropped it in the pool and it
became the size of like a small boat
as it absorbed the water and i i
couldn't read it even then
so i didn't actually read it until that
got the part of pippin
right and then at that point i was
living in glasgow and working in
edinburgh
and i had an hour on the train every day
back and forward to the theater where i
was
in a play and i read it on the train
back and forward it's wonderful
and i read it thinking about pippin so
brilliant so in my head it's a story
about pippin and some other people
wizards and all that
but mainly pippin i mean that's probably
as it should be as an
actor right you approach it as you know
what is my
character doing but how great to have
read it in terms of
i'm going to play this character do you
know at that point you were going to
play yeah
yeah that's brilliant isn't it good i
mean what an extraordinary but
i i've had so many great experiences
reading books
over the years and i wouldn't say that
lord rings is my favorite book in the
world
although it's in my top five but
absolutely the top of the list in terms
of
the most immersed i've felt in a world
yeah i couldn't believe how much this
you know genius level writer tolkien
was able to paint a world in my mind
that felt like i was in it and walking
around in it and
yeah and you look forward to going back
to the book to get back into that world
right
i mean my mum who obviously you spent a
lot of time with when they came over to
new zealand and subsequently
i joked with my mum and dad before they
came out to new zealand my dad had read
the book probably
i don't know more than five times and i
said to my parents to my mum
if you're going to come over mum you
have to read lord the rings come on
you're going to meet gollum you're going
to meet
gandalf and pippin and frodo you need to
know what these people are
and she said uh wizards and magic and
monsters i said don't worry about that
don't worry it's not that it's it's
characters yeah it's it's people you
love you know
so she said well i'll give it a go and
she absolutely
loved it and like since my mom has never
read any books about wizards and magic
and yeah elves and anything like that
since and i said well mom
honestly you don't need to they broke
the mold with that book yeah really
okay so who's the next one yeah let's
get another question
hey billion dom this is taylor i was
just wondering why do you think you two
formed such a strong friendship
and what is it that you like about each
other and what annoys you about each
other
that's that's a good question actually
from taylor we have to be careful we
don't
very very careful this is only the first
podcast
i'm not sure really i think it's i think
there's
sometimes a little bit of hard to
explain
kind of chemistry magic about a
friendship that
i'm not fully able to work out like
yeah we've spent a lot of time with each
other yeah
too much somewhat too much some people
would say but certainly principal
photography and
and reshoots later spent a lot of time
with each other i mean i remember being
quite aghast
at the the fact of the matter being that
we would
shoot in the day yeah get picked up at
maybe
five five thirty rap at
six six thirty sometimes seven and then
a lot of us say right where we going for
dinner instead of
even if you like each other kind of
saying right guys
brilliant see you tomorrow but i need to
go home
and be on my own we we did we did
gravitate around each other and i don't
think it was
forced right now yeah and i think
do you think there's anything i'm just
thinking about it just now do you think
there's anything
in that we grew up in big
british cities like you're a manchester
guy
i'm a glasgow guy we sort of understood
each other's
music as we grew up you know we
we go to a pub and have a pint and play
a game at pool
we understood that sort of shared
history even though it was totally
different yeah but
it was different from the people who
grew up in l.a or
had a new zealand upbringing that we
understood that sort of
yeah we're the sort of shared thing
there i don't know maybe that's part of
it
i think that's certainly part of it that
elijah was
too young to be going out and drinking
in bars when he came to new zealand
sean astin had a young daughter he
didn't really seem
to be in a place in his life where he
was going to be
doing that as much orlando obviously
hung out with us a lot but like you said
i
i was 23 when i did load the ring so i
had spent at least
five years pretty routinely
in that pub based banter let's play pool
have some fun with each other i
certainly didn't go out of my way to
think
it's important for me to be friends with
pippin i knew that it was
but i didn't think right well i should
probably go for dinner with him and uh
we should probably
maybe just play pool together one night
just to get to know each other it was
nothing was
no forced was it i don't know if you
remember but i think on the first day of
filming
you gave me a little card i don't
remember this at all
and it said uh i'll watch your back if
you watch mine
no did i really yeah that is new
information
there you go hang on are you sure it was
me um
yep wait so had i written i'll watch you
back oh that was part of the card
no you'd written it handwritten wow
yeah it's a shame you don't still have
it that's complete maybe i do
wow well you know i think
that's that's a crazy thing it's amazing
what you forget isn't it um
mary and pippin are obviously great
mates and sometimes in the script just
going through a day
yeah of me needing to protect you
or you needing to make sure that i'm
okay i think
that that kind of facade
creates something real as well yeah yeah
and it's ongoing i don't know as as
brits i think we also probably both
don't explore the whys behind the
friendship as much you just do it don't
you
yeah yeah there's yeah you don't get too
deep into it i like spending time with
you
so i just spend time with you and we
make each other laugh
i said yeah some of my you know most fun
times is
just you coming down the house and
talking about stuff
and that's i suppose that's why we're
doing this and what annoys me
about you absolutely nothing tell oh man
i had such a long list then
but now it feels like i can't do
anything um what annoys me about yeah i
can't think of anything off the top of
my
head um maybe
maybe you had that you went well i've
got one but it's not this is this is
more a gripe about
me carry on
maybe sometimes if i'm
irked by something or or
or annoyed by a person or or
whatever something's got on my nerves
sometimes if i tell you the story
yeah you adopt quite rightly a devil's
advocate type thing
and sometimes i needed to be like yeah
that was terrible and you're right and
sometimes i should just listen well no
you do listen but you always you
adopt the very sensible thing of
philosophical of like
well you know dom sometimes you know
these people
they may have had a bad day and you
can't be sure about
motives and i always think damn he's a
better person than me
no no you're right there john i'm good
yeah
i'm i'm going to be more team dumb also
here's a here's just a uh a gripe from a
physical point of view
i think you can drink more alcohol than
me yeah and
probably not show that you're
as tipsy as me so sometimes if we're
having a glass of wine together and it's
turned into opening another bottle of
wine
i think oh i'm a little i'm a little
part
two sheets to the wind i wonder how
billy's doing and i look her over you
and i think
he's absolutely fine yeah i don't i
don't drink it he's gonna have a good
night's sleep
take his dog for an early morning walk
and i'm gonna wake up and be like oh god
that's
terrible do you have a hangover cure now
in your old age
no i think i think hangovers get worse
so
like you know drinking gets less as you
get older doesn't it because
it's not as much fun yeah that's a good
point hi billy
and dom my name is alex i'm so excited
for this podcast
um what would you say some of your
favorite movies were growing up that
maybe inspired you guys to become
actors thanks alex good questions
actually good question for the first
week
i think this is good questions and also
as actors
most actors tend to be obsessed with
movies at some point yeah that's right
what about you all right here's my quick
as quick as i can
answer to that there's there's a thing
in britain
or there used to be called butlins
butlands was a holiday camp
where your parents would you know pay
whatever it was and you went there
and then everything was free so there'd
be
uh you know a fun park where you
you go on the roller coaster and it was
free you didn't pay every time
there was a theater a cinema that was
free
but not really not really because your
mum and dad have paid but but you don't
pay every time you go
when i was there there was a couple of
movies there was return
of pink panther or a pink panther
strikes again actually how old are you
at this point not
sure okay ish 10
12 okay and also
there was the seven voyages of sinbad
oh right with those crazy special
effects harry housing
mm-hmm right and i remember i would go
there
every day to watch those movies at some
point during the day i would go in
and watch those movies so those were
huge for me
now as a grown-up can you repeatedly
watch movies are you kind of one and
done
one and done right there's only a few
movies i'll re-watch with neil and i
spinal tap brilliant gregory's girl oh
brilliant
they're done that those those three just
smashed out the park
um movies that are influential for me
growing up
i mean i don't want to be boring and say
star wars but i feel like i'm
going to just because as a kid
it was it it was the kind of
bridge between i like films
and this is a really fun experience for
me to be sitting in front of
the tv watching them and that could be
something i could
do because i remember asking my dad
how come han solo was also harrison
it was also indiana jones because i was
confused
i was just confused you know my dad said
oh he's an actor so he
he is harrison ford in this film and
then he's indiana jones and this one he
puts on a different
outfit and and reads different lines and
i remember thinking
oh okay so it's a job and you can do it
for a career and that was a big
light bulb so
probably star wars i wonder how many
people around the world
would have said that in some way those
first three star wars movies
change the course of their life because
that's another kind of
seismic moment in in movie history isn't
it
yeah huge but i think of a certain age
when you're a certain age
a lot of movies can hit you quite hard
and stay with you forever you know yeah
brilliant okay great question alex
bills yeah you had mentioned one time to
me which i think is
a brilliant comment that one of your
favorite things about being an actor
is the fact that you travel to all these
different places around the world
and experts in different fields come
in and teach you what they've known
by them learning everything that it is
to know about
sword fighting or horse riding or what
it means to be a golfer or what it means
yeah
i love that and i think that's one of my
favorite things about being an actor as
well
the other thing for me that i love about
being an actor
is this built-in travel element that
forces you to embrace other countries
cultures
travel is very important very important
it's very good for the mind and i know
you and i
have over the years been quite
adventurous with our
eating of different foods you and i took
a trip to
thailand in which we basically said to
the chefs there
what's great bring us that with that
in mind but not in thai we just said it
in english
i'm just remembering the time that we we
actually took
a canoe across to an island
in thailand because someone said there's
an amazing restaurant with an amazing
chef
but you have to you have to get yourself
over there all of those facts were true
so we canoed over took about 30 minutes
to get
to this roasting hot sun right
it was it was a solid if you're talking
american
100 degrees and in celsius 35
plus degrees on the top of your head
excruciatingly hot
we got there they mainly spoke thai
but we said which we loved we said we'll
take this
and it turns out it was sort of raw
shrimps
done in like super hot chilies and if
you remember
the chef came out and said no you guys
don't want this yeah he said
are you aware of what you've ordered
because this is raw shrimp
that in some way cook in the heat of the
chili oil and the garlic
and spices and we said give us ten of
them
bring them over we said we'll have two
orders of that
and we ate it and i was sweating dog
they were great though right
they were delicious but it was difficult
it was a difficult eat
top and then we finished we had a drink
and we said we've got to canoe ourselves
back now and if you remember the sun was
going down
the fish were flying out of the water do
you remember that
yeah what was that is that flying fish
fish because i remember saying to you
flying fish and you went
where but
flying fish and then i don't know if you
remember dom
but i had a tremendous diarrhea panic
yeah which is not common for you i don't
know another time in our lives
no you've said i really need the
bathroom i really need to go because
i've got a very strong stomach
i can anything and and we were on i knew
that it was 30 minutes back
and i thought am i because we were quite
close by this time
but not close enough that i could
purchase myself
over a canoe yeah and let myself go
that's what i thought was gonna happen i
thought you're gonna say
dom look away look away don't paddle
anymore
don't look back i'm gonna fit i'm gonna
feed the flying fish and then you would
just hear those gentle
plops into the ocean but thankfully you
kept i i managed i think the strength in
you got
more because of the flying fish than you
i was just
i was scared of the flying fish you know
what they might do what if suddenly this
yeah so i managed to
hold myself but that it's always stayed
with me we got to the shoreline
and as soon as your feet could touch the
bottom you said that's it i'm off
all right and i had to haul you had to
deal with it all this canoe
up to the guy who'd rented us and then
by the time i got to the hotel room
you were absolutely delighted with what
happened
and you were just lying on your bed
underneath the air conditioner going
oh i'm so relieved i'm sorry
so which brings us quite nicely that was
a roundabout way of saying
we like food from around the world and
what better way to start
than with what has basically become
a kind of cliched usa
staple snack food which is i reach for
it delicately
the twinkie a twinkie dom
i'd like to call this piece of the show
dom
and billy eat the world oh that's great
so if you guys out there have maybe
something from
the country that you come from which is
a local delicacy or a treat or a
piece of food that you're proud about
that we might be able to get hold of
here in the united states make some
suggestions because we love being
introduced
to new food what is what do you know
thus far about a twinkie
now here's the thing tom i have never in
my life
eaten a twinkie i've never eaten a
twinkie
in my mind and this might not be true
somehow i feel as if i read somewhere it
was invented for space travel
for spouse travel like for astronauts to
eat
in space right why would i think that
would be true
i'm wondering if maybe you've confused
it with the
idea that it doesn't seem to degrade at
all
on planet earth so it might be able to
survive in a spaceship but my
understanding of
space food is that it all has to be
dehydrated and then
hydrated back in space if you bring
something that has any
level of moisture through the atmosphere
i think it completely sucks it all out
of it
that's my understanding well i think
we're both
got very good facts for people there and
neither of those facts i think would be
true
well i'll tell you what i know about the
twinkie snack food very often found in
7-elevens in the united states a
favorite of woody harrelson's character
in
zombieland he was on the search for
twinkies all the time
i've never eaten one they're always
available in a 7-eleven the thing that
unnerves me even before i open it is
they always have this kind of slightly
oily
greasy kind of vibe to them where they
stick
to the cellophane that they're wrapping
have you seen that i have seen that
they're known for being well let's be
let's be as politically correct as we
can about this they're known for being
not that good for you really yeah well
and for you said that they last for
virtually ever
mine has a sale by day of june the 6th
2021 oh okay so then you probably
couldn't take him in space
i will say this i'm not tasting it yet
but the smell
is quite nice it smells like a sponge
cake i went to smell my twinkie there
and accidentally
smelt the make which is kind of twinkie
shaped
i was trying to work out what the what
the shape of a twinkie was earlier on do
you know anything about
like is this a rhomboid potentially
well it's difficult to say isn't it it
has um
if anyone who's never seen a twinkie
sticky
sticky yeah that's crazy sticky alert i
think you keep it on the cardboard right
well yeah i for me this isn't a great
way to describe it but it looks like
a 3d clock with
the the sixth hour cut off
does that make sense like if you're
looking at a clip absolutely not
really i think if you're looking at a
clock's face so i'm looking at both the
twinkies here or
oh just one of them like this one
individual twinkie if you imagine it
like a clock's
face yeah moving backwards away from you
it's getting quite surreal now
the the sixth hour has been bitten off
hey
no no it's like salvador dali the way
you're
what are you talking about clock face
well let's just eat it then all right
hold on
should we do it together i don't like
the fact that it's left quite a heavy
amount of the twinkie on the cardboard
yeah and it's left quite a lot on my
thumb as well
now i think you have to get quite deep
into it because i don't just want to get
the sponge i want to get the inside as
well
ready ready i don't think you'll like it
from three
from three two one
twinkie
it's moist
yeah it's like calm creamy sponge
quite spongy
it's not bad i mean as a as a brit
as an english man i would like this with
a cup of tea
i think it needs something to cut into
it a lot oh yeah so a nice a nice strong
cup of tetley or something
marks out of ten um you know what i'm
going to say it's better than i expected
same would you mind if i had the second
bite no i think you should
i feel as though i don't have much cream
in my twinkie
get deeper in that seems to be where the
where the cream filling is
right hold on i wonder if this is the
type of thing
that in a couple of hours makes another
appearance do you know what i mean like
you kind of go
oh twinkie oh that's a that's like a
clock face without the six
do you think i'm actually cause your
son's quite a taste maker do you think
your son would like something like this
i don't think my son's ever had a
twinkie either but um
i tell you what dom that's a lot better
than i thought it was going to be
i'm going to finish mine which is all
credit to the twinkie
i thought i was going to have one bite
and say
that's far too sickly yeah but i
actually quite like it and i think
you're right a nice cup of tea
not too much milk not too much milk in
it no no sugar in that one
but just a nice strong cup of tea just
to take that that sweet edge off yeah
here's a cool piece of trivia go on then
it's a very popular confectionary treat
in mexico
where they're called submarines
that seems to make sense with the shape
right now a submarine
that makes sense much more than a clock
face with the six being bitten off
i'll be i won't be able to sleep tonight
try to work out what you were talking
about i have to admit i was kind of
reaching for something there
but just to conclude because we'd love
to hear from you guys
if you have something that you maybe
grew up on
or something that you found on your
travels which is hard for you to
uh get in in your local area or
something that you think billy and i
will be in some way delighted
to try out send it to us or tell us
where we can find it give us all the
information about it we would love
to eat the world i'm going to give a
twinkie
a 7 out of 10 much better than i thought
it was going to be
and i could see myself ordering a
twinkie with a nice cup of tea
i'm going to give a twinkie a
5.9 out of 10. i didn't know we could do
points oh sorry
carry on 5.9 out of 10 better than i
expected
but there's two twinkies in a box and i
can't get through the second one
that's because they're made to share
lovely
twinkies made to share billy
yes i've always wanted to be a quiz
master you know like one of those old
fashioned guys who like asked questions
on the tv you
would be brilliant and now yeah we get a
chance to live out that dream because
now we're gonna have a little
quiz moment this is a good thing about
the podcast we can do whatever we want
john whatever we want and i think as the
weeks go on yeah
maybe we turn this into a quiz where in
some way you might win some sort of
prize but at this point i don't think we
can offer anything apart from just a
congratulatory nod
in their direction oh i think we'll need
you all for more than that surely
should we introduce our two guests and
see what they might want to steal from
the studio behind us so
what's up guys so we have joey hey joey
how's it going hi joey
how you doing pleasure to meet y'all
pleasure to meet you too and your
fellow contestant is tyler
hey guys hello tyler hey you're totally
welcome now
before we begin this quiz which we have
in front of us which seems to be very
lord of the rings he based
what's you guys is lord of the rings
knowledge at this point would you say
joey how about you go first uh i say uh
with the movies i
very well versed especially in all the
extended editions i've watched them
you know i grew up on lord of the rings
so i say with the movies i'm very well
well versed the books not so much okay
that sounds like a good start
yes tyler
i've seen the uh the movies once or
twice um
a year um and the books i've read a
couple times as well
oh now tyler was quite cool there he
went i've seen the movies once or twice
a year right not just once or twice once
or twice
a year and he also knows the books which
you know sways things a little
tyler's way maybe so so we're gonna ask
you guys questions but
the only other thing that i'll tell you
guys is if
either one of you gets stuck you get one
opportunity to ask one of us
for a clue but only one opportunity so
make sure you spend that golden ticket
wisely got it gotcha bills do you want
to go first
first question which is is this to one
of them or to both i
feel like it's two it must be to one of
them because they don't have a buzzer
neither of you guys have a bell or a
buzzer do you
no no i don't have a buzzer in front of
me no first question
then to joey joey
what is a hobbit's favorite food
is it a mushrooms b
limbus bread c ale
or d blueberries
oh i would say it was food correct
yes food i would say mushrooms correct
joy gets one that's a good start
fantastic start actually
off to the races i feel like that was
kind of an easy question well we've got
to start a little easier it's a good
point
all right tyler you good you ready i'm
ready
in the movie the lord of the rings who
said we've had one yes but what about
second breakfast
was it mary pippin
frodo awesome
i believe that was um
he's struggling oh mary
is that your final answer mary final
the answer's pippin we've had one yes
but what about second breakfast the
scottish accent
should have given it away now
second breakfast is actually in the book
isn't it i don't know
actually i think they do talk about
second breakfast and elevenses and
afternoon tea i think they'll talk about
it i've always wanted to check that
because i can't remember because that
day if you remember was quite hectic
yeah and i can't remember how that line
came up but
i can't remember if it send a book i'm
pretty positive it's in the book but
there we go all right
joey it's one nothing you're in the lead
good man
now tell me what is the name of the
volcano
where the ring is thrown into
is it mount doom or skilliath
meanest tirath or baradur
that's mount doom or skilliath
meanest tirath or baradur
it's uh mount doom fantastic that's true
for joey no it's not right
nope that's wrong it's about to do it
[Laughter]
it's called baradura yeah yeah is that
mount doom
no mount doom is the mountain
where the volcano is situated
situated there's the massive mountain
that they're climbing
is the place is this that wasn't an easy
tough one yeah an easy question and
they're getting harder joey they're
getting harder
still one nil to joey tyler you can
catch up here you can tie this edge all
right
what is the name of the most popular pub
in the shire in the shire
is it the prancing pony the green dragon
the black board or the burgundy lion
it's the green dragon that's the correct
answer that is the correct answer one
one one nice joy
joy it's another multiple choice and it
is what does aragorn see
right before charging into the battle
in mordor does he say
for frodo not with that accent but does
he
does he say freedom
does he say hope conquers all
or does he say middle earth will not
fall today
he says uh for frodo but not in your
awesome scottish accent he does joy
you're up again he's 2-1 again is that
in the book or is that just in the film
does
does aragorn actually say four frodo in
the book i'm not sure he does you know i
don't know tyler's read the book
i don't know he doesn't know either
if you guys know tell us next week so
that we can report back
yeah all right uh tyler so you what
so it's 2-1 is it to joey 2-1 enjoy and
this is quite a difficult one i think
tyler i'm not sure about that
okay uh tyler here we go which of the
following areas in middle earth has
legolas
not been to is it
helms deep rivendell
the shire or eisenguard
which which area middle earth has
legless not been to
i'm gonna have to go with the shire is
the correct
answer oh that was a difficult one as
well because he'd be kicked out of the
shire for being
too well uh groomed oh he's very
beautiful
yeah the hobbits like people to be a
little rougher around the edges maybe
your hair's grown out maybe you smell of
carrots
yeah you smell a poo a little bit food
in your beard legless wouldn't have any
of that
oh nothing no it's two two it's two two
joey and here's quite a difficult one
what causes mary and pippin
to grow taller when they are in fangone
forest is it the white wizard
sorcery tree beard's magic spell
the ant water or the ant
food it's the uh the ant water
causes them to grow tall that's very
very good he's good isn't it
and they become the two tallest hobbits
in history the two tallest hobbits that
ever lived and
some of my favorite improvisational
stuff that pete
allowed you and i to do in the movie was
remember there was a there was a point
where
you and i were in the same frame
together but we we weren't on the same
island we weren't able to see each other
and pete said what if the two of you
without the other one looking are trying
to measure
how tall we are do you remember that
moment yeah i do i think that was was
that near
saruman's tower i think so the fall of
simon's tower yeah and we're both like
this
an eisenguard that was funny brilliant
all right tyler what's the score is it
two
is it three two to joey yes it is i
think three two the jerk
very fair of you there tyler well very
close very close very close all right
question eight we're coming towards the
end here
uh tyler other than sting
frodo's sword what was the other gift
that bilbo gave frodo to use for
protection
on his journey was it a crossbow
was it a mithril vest
was it lambast bread or was it of course
that medicinal pipe weed
well probably some pipe weed but it's
the uh
mithril vest it's the correct answer
it's three three this is a clash of the
titans episode one
so i am gonna give this question to joy
joy who said
oh it's quite simple if you are a friend
you speak the password and the doors
will
open was that mary pippin
bilbo or gandalf
that would be uh gandalf he's absolutely
right dom correct answer
that no what does that mean the score i
think is that four
three to joey yeah
four three so that means this is for a
draw
this is for a draw you need to get this
tyler we might be able to find a time
right no pressure
a time breaker question if we need one
okay
tyler concentrate this is to draw it
in the movies not the book in the movies
how many times does frodo wear the ring
while on his journey to destroy it i
think that's the hardest
i think that's the hardest question that
is a tough one don't even think i can
answer that i don't think even joey
could get this one
that's a rough one that's tough that's
you want to give them options
you ready tyler i'm ready okay the
options are
does he put the ring on once
twice four times
or five in the entire trilogy
that's a tough question on the way yes
one
two four or five and remember
you still have your golden ticket you
can ask either me or dom
to give you a clue since dom since
you're reading that to me
i need a clue okay i'll give you a clue
i know it's in the um prancing pony for
sure
[Music]
well hang on if i give you this clue
will it completely
that's gonna ruin it okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna go oh you're just gonna go
with it anyway
twice you say in the entire trilogy puts
it on twice
you should have asked me for the clue
i've got a great wait ask billy ask
billy for a clue
go on bailey so it's either one
two four or five okay
all right i'm gonna go with four oh he's
there he's not monocle he doesn't want
one
it's the correct answer he's done it
hey it's a tie it's a tie breaker that's
the tie breaker
i'm on week one we've got we've got our
tiebreaker question as we can't believe
it
and if whoever gets this right wins
this chair right producer
we will sign this chair that's yet to be
confirmed
but you might win a chair and i get so
excited i just broke wind on it
which it's worth more now
[Laughter]
billy do you want to do the time break
question no you do dumb i'm too excited
so this is it's almost like a two-part
follow-on from what we just had so
if it's for all do you guys want to just
shout out the answer if you know it and
whoever shouts it first
wins i think well i think somebody
presses a buzzer
make that noise and then you get to
answer first
and then the next person if you don't
get it correct the next person does it
okay copy that all right here we go so
here's
they're both going to buzz at the same
time so here's
here's your question chaps for all the
marbles
how many times does frodo wear the ring
in the book is it four times
five times six times or 12 times
i'll guess oh and that was a buzzer from
tyler there tyler
four times five times six times or
twelve
times that's four five six or twelve
let's go uh six let's not say whether
it's true or false
joey do you wanna have a an answer you
could answer six as well if you want or
you could go somewhere else
what's it what's the what's the things
again four times yes
five times six times or 12 times
well i'm gonna say since he said six i'm
gonna say you know there's probably a
lot more
you know context in the book i'm gonna
go ahead and just guess 12 because i'm
not i'm not entirely sure
guys the correct answer
is five
i'm sorry guys guys you both win a chair
you both win nothing brilliant yeah
well i see two chairs
guys that was tremendous knowledge if
you don't mind me saying that was
absolutely wonderful i quite like the
fact that the first quiz
ended in a very friendly draw i think
that's wonderful
if we think if we think of it of
anything to send you guys we will send
you
something yeah we'll try and raid the
fridges around here and see what we can
say
thank you for being our first guests
hey thanks for having us yeah this is
awesome i wanted to meet you guys you
guys are amazing
nice to meet you guys too see you thank
you bye
bye bye honestly bills how many of those
questions would you got right
every single one billy yes dom
circling back around just very casually
to
the lord of the rings trilogy yeah yeah
someone has sent
us in a movie clip we don't know
whereabouts it's from in the trilogy for
us to watch
and then maybe just break down what was
happening for us
in that time in our life exciting dom
should we we're going to watch it now we
don't know what it is we're going to
click this link
oh you're in charge of the clicker i
like that
here we go and here's a clip
it's from the fellowship of the ring oh
there's a hint
and here it comes where are you taking
us into the wild
[Music]
how do we know this strider is a friend
of gandalf
i think a servant of the enemy would
look fairer
feel foulder he's foul enough
we have no choice but to trust him
but where is he leading us rivendell
master ganji
the house of elrond did you hear that
we're going to see the elves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gentlemen we do not stop till nightfall
what about breakfast i've already had it
we've had one yes
what about second breakfast
i don't think he knows about second
breakfast pip
what about elevensies luncheon afternoon
tea
dinner supper he knows about them
doesn't he
i wouldn't count on it
[Music]
well i have to say wow we watched that
in perfect silence
well yeah maybe we were just consumed by
what was
going on there on screen oh yeah maybe
we should have said something as that
was happening well i don't know
i we were talking about this the other
day you and i
i don't tend to watch my
work outside of making sure what i've
done is
not embarrassing and that i can speak
about the film
simply because and it happened just then
anytime i watch
anything that i do yeah i always think i
could definitely do
i've done that better isn't that always
the way in art though
yeah it might be true and it's i'm not
being hypocritical and
weirdly whatever sexy yeah
not being super sexy right now i just
think
because i enjoy the process so much i
always think
oh there's another way to have attacked
that and another way and another way and
like you say
it might just be the the element
of art that you can always add colors
yeah
i think so i think ted hughes the
the poet laureate he he would write a
poem
and then he said i just leave it and
never go back to it and try and
do a second draft or make it better
because you just that's just
that's the piece of art that was done
there you go just leave it
nice and i watched that and i loved you
in that dumb oh thanks buzz i always
love you in it and i love viggo in it
and i love elijah and sean and all those
other people
for me i just think i'm hypocritical but
to break down what we've just seen
i think that particular sequence was
shot
in different areas of new zealand on
different days
right definitely because i have a very
vivid memory
of this the second part of it the second
breakfast part
in the snow because that was a really
exciting
crazy day brilliant the first part of it
which i forgot about that part i have no
memory
of filming that at all i don't remember
that either i do remember days when it
was
yourself elijah and sean and i
always feeling very frenetic
and pacey and fast
because certainly with the four boys the
four hobbits
there was always something going on
right we're all listening to music
having lunch together running around
playing games
i absolutely don't have any recollection
of that
first bit that we shot either although
interestingly it would have been
one of the first times that we did
something with veg
yeah you would think if it's an order i
can't remember because the first thing
we did with vega was weathertop and i
think we started getting into
walking through the forest with was that
particular part of
new zealand the place that was infested
with sand flies because remember we got
lit up by sand flies no that was a
different part that was once we
we went to the marshes wasn't it that
was fun
so on this on that on that day on the
second breakfast day
because you can obviously maybe talk a
little bit more about second breakfast
and where all that came from
but we had found ourselves in a
massive flash snowstorm yeah huge that
the crew couldn't
predict and the only reason why i'm
saying that is because
most film crews will have a pretty
accurate
weather forecast of what's gonna happen
yeah and none of them
really knew that snow was coming in
until like an hour before it happened
and then we were done
yeah and i think that we had planned uh
that scene to be you know a lot of
close-ups and
you know as we take the pans off to get
ready to
cook breakfast and all that and then
they were like
we've got an hour we need to shoot this
and it was basically one wide shot and
then you know
ideas were coming fast what if you threw
me an apple and it hit me in the head
and blah blah
and i remember being at the time
disappointed that
oh this was such a going to be such a
nice scene
and it feels like totally rush now and
they were like okay we need to get the
vans out
and they went first and and we were
still filming as people were
you know trying to get out of the
snowstorm because they're like we're
going to get stuck
on this mountain yeah and we almost did
our driver
was sliding all over the road in the
snow trying to get us home
i like the fact that an apple came back
into the scene
because if you notice with me at least
when you first see mary
at the start of fellowship of the ring
he's eating apples later on throughout
the film
he's eating apples and i think viggo
might have suggested to pete
well what if i throw them something yeah
bread or a banana or something
and peter said apples it has to be
apples um
it did feel very rushed from my side of
things i was just having a great day
because suddenly the snow had come
and there was a feeling with the film
set of like
we're going to need to rap in the next
hour yeah and i was thinking
oh wow i thought i was going to be here
till yeah five in the afternoon and
suddenly
we're rapping in the next 45 minutes to
an hour pete
jackson from what i recall was quite
giddy with the energy of it all right
okay remember he was like we gotta go
guys
we gotta go come on grab your stuff and
let's go and just kind of grabbing it on
the fly um but i
i think it's in the books that hobbits
in their normal daily life
have breakfast a second breakfast
elevenses
lunch afternoon tea dinner
and a supper i think i might be missing
one thing out but
so it just it's it's academic for us
that we're like well of course we're
stopping of course we're starting this
time
it's second breakfast and i love the
humor of aragon saying
well no you've had breakfast and then
you correct him well yeah but i had one
do you know we're gonna have five or six
meals in the not too distant future
and strider probably has a meal every
four days or something
the culture shock between how a human
eats at that point and how the hobbit
seat was was really sweet
i i love the fact that quite rightly
the ghost character even though he's
guiding us through all this he's very
much removed from that hobbit world he
doesn't really
understand the nuances of what it means
to be a hobbit no
we're a bit of a bother to him at this
point yeah totally
and and strangely enough i don't know if
you remember but
because it was difficult to get to get
off
of this set when we got back we went
in our makeup trailers because they had
to be taken off somewhere else
so we were in the small hotel that we
were in
sitting on top of washing machines in
the
washer dryer room because it takes an
hour to get all the hobbit feet off and
the hobbit ears and the wigs
and if you remember the makeup people
were taking our shoes off
in this washer dryer room and it was
freezing cold
and viggo turned up with a bottle of
whiskey yeah
and gave us all a little dram of whiskey
a little
drink that tried to warm us up in the
snow
yeah and i thought wow look look at
strider looking after the hobbits yeah
yeah helping us out
and that also turned into a couple of
other things
one of which was a kind of impromptu
photo shoot i think that's right
camera that's right and he shot a few
images of you and myself and elijah in
the snow
and then after a couple more whiskies
turned into a massive snowball fight
that's right crazy what what a strange
and wonderful day
it sort of sums up the the filming of
the movies actually
that sort of adapting to what's going on
but yet
feeling like you're on an adventure it's
great and as time
has gone on that second breakfast thing
seems to have grown and got stronger and
stronger in fact i
sent bills an image the other day
in a supermarket of a section of
kind of fruits and vegetables mushrooms
and tomatoes and stuff
and mary and pippin that had been drawn
in the supermarket and you saying well
what about second breakfast so
it's become this like reason for you to
have an extra snack
after breakfast which i love so if you
guys have second breakfast
tell us about it if that's something
that you've actually brought into your
daily practice yes please please tell us
about your second breakfast
as a note well dom i think we've reached
about the end of our first ever podcast
yes but it's very important at this
point to tell people to rate
subscribe and review the podcast because
it helps us
do more podcasts talk about more things
and you guys get a chance to hear us you
know giggle on about
rubbish you're a very wise man oh thanks
anywhere you guys listen to podcasts you
can listen to this podcast and also
we're going to be up on youtube right
yeah if you want to have a look at us
that's where you'll see us
at the friendship onion the friendship
onion
and next week maybe we'll get into a
little bit about that time that you and
i were arrested and spent time in that
latvian prison yeah we'll not get time
for that just now
no no time now i'm going to get a
twinkie see you next week goodbye